italia se ha convertido para muchos en
el mayor peligro en la mayor amenaza
para toda la eurozona porque en este
vídeo te lo contamos
una de occidente' la pasta las pizzas o
de técnicas para hacer el café tan
populares como el capuchino el ristretto
o el expreso. Italia queridos amigos de
visual político se ha convertido en todo
un quebradero de cabeza para los líderes
europeos y es que hablamos de un gigante
que podría llegar a convertirse en todo
un titán
una crisis económica y financiera que
dejaría la crisis griega como un juego
de niños y es que veréis hoy por hoy
italia es la octava mayor economía del
planeta pero es un país que no crece
cuyo sistema bancario tiene muchísimos
problemas y cuyo gobierno está endeudado
hasta las cejas fijaos la deuda pública
italiana supera ya el 130 el 130 por
ciento del pib lo que hace que a pesar
de que italia sea tras alemania el reino
unido y francia- la cuarta economía de
la unión europea el país tenga el mayor
stock de deuda pública en total más de
25 billones de dólares para que os
hagáis una idea de todo lo que esto
supone podemos decir que la deuda
pública italiana equivale a dos veces el
tamaño de toda la economía mexicana oa
casi cuatro veces el de la economía
suiza y no tengamos dudas eso es mucho
pero que mucho dinero
pero aquí no terminan todos los
problemas para nada la economía italiana
apenas crece de hecho aún no ha
conseguido recuperar los niveles
anteriores a las crisis de 2008 el
desempleo supera el 10% y el paro
juvenil ronda el 40 el 40 por ciento
de hecho y tal es uno de los países con
más ninis de todo el mundo de jóvenes
que ni estudian ni trabajan a todo esto
tenemos que sumarle que año tras año la
deuda pública continúa subiendo no para
de crecer y crecer que el país tiene un
problema de envejecimiento de la
población muy importante y que encima
del banco central europeo que durante
los últimos años ha sido el mayor
comprador de deuda pública italiana
ahora puede dejar de hacerlo el banco
central europeo- dice que su programa de
compra masiva de bonos terminará
probablemente en diciembre con todo esto
es cómo podemos entender noticias como
estas
italia está empujando a europa al borde
de otra crisis económica se ahonda la
crisis en italia que hace temblar a la
unión europea pero ahora bien puede que
alguno de vosotros esté preguntando
enrique los problemas de los que me
estás hablando no son precisamente
nuevos entonces porque justo ahora
italia vuelva a estar en el candelero
porque vuelve a ocupar las portadas de
los periódicos por qué diantres ahora de
repente nos preocupa tanto pues bien
atentos
nuevo gobierno la marcha atrás
tras meses de incertidumbre finalmente
en junio de 2018 un nuevo gobierno llegó
al poder y ojo porque no hablamos de
cualquier gobierno
capitaneado por el primer ministro josep
conté hablamos de un gobierno formado
por el euroescéptico y antisistema
movimiento cinco estrellas y por la liga
un partido muy pero que muy de derechas
la nueva coalición llegaba con una idea
muy clara la sobran italiana volvería a
estar en roma y no en bruselas lo que la
mayoría de los casos no suele significar
nada excepto que quieren gastar más
pues bien el caso es que como sabéis los
países que forman parte de la zona euro
es decir que comparten la misma moneda
acuerdan con las autoridades europeas
una especie de metas unos niveles
máximos de déficit público y también una
senda sobre cómo van a evolucionar estos
déficits con el paso de los años
todo ello para mantener la estabilidad y
la solvencia y reducir así el riesgo de
crisis pues bien al nuevo gobierno
italiano esto no le gusta ni un pelo
senda de déficit a ver a ver a ver que
tú me vas a decir a mí lo que puedo no
puedo gastar pues lo llevas claro esto
es más o menos lo que debieron de pensar
en el nuevo gobierno de tal forma que
una de las primeras cosas que han hecho
ha sido presentar en septiembre una
propuesta de presupuestos donde el
déficit público sería sustancialmente
mayor que el que estaba comprometido con
bruselas y ahí es cuando se produjo el
terremoto y tal le desafía la unión
europea y sube el déficit al 2,4 por
ciento del pib un nuevo gobierno que
llega para gastar más pero si
precisamente lo que italia tienes un
problemón de deuda pública y lo que
quieren ahora es pedir más y más deuda
ver para creer porque amigos un 2,4 por
ciento puede parecernos poco pero si
tenemos en cuenta que la previsión es
que la economía italiana no crezca más
que un 1 por ciento un raquítico 1 por
ciento los próximos años entonces la
cosa cambia porque lo que significa ese
2 con 4 por ciento es que cada año que
pasa
italia será menos solvente tendrá un
menos capacidad para pagar pues bien
sabéis cuál ha sido el resultado de todo
este pulso entre el nuevo gobierno lo
escéptico y bruselas fija
desde que se conoció la orientación del
nuevo gobierno de giuseppe conté la
rentabilidad del bono a 10 años de
italia se ha disparado más de un 90 por
ciento es decir los inversores entienden
que hay mucho más riesgo y por tanto
exigen más rentabilidad para prestarles
su dinero evidentemente eso supone que
cada vez que el gobierno italiano emite
deuda tiene que pagar muchos más
intereses
y ojo porque hasta 2020 italia se
enfrenta a vencimientos de deuda por
casi 600 mil millones de dólares importe
que por supuesto tendrá que volver a
pedir a los mercados junto a los déficit
que acumule hasta entonces en total más
de 700 mil millones de dólares que
locura de cifras nos parece
pues bien si los inversores piden más
rentabilidad los intereses serán más
altos y por tanto lo será también el
déficit público y si además el banco
central europeo deja de comprar deuda
eso podría suponer intereses aún
muchísimo más altos hasta el punto de
que toda esa espiral podría poner contra
las cuerdas al gobierno italiano primero
y a sus bancos después que son
propietarios de buena parte de la deuda
italiana y además parece difícil que
pudieran soportar una nueva recesión los
bancos italianos se tropiezan con una
nueva crisis y desde luego no penséis
que hay acabaría todo para nada
italia amigos no es grecia su enorme
tamaño implicaría que la crisis
financiera podría extenderse por toda la
eurozona bueno eso sería casi seguro por
eso las políticas del nuevo gobierno
italiano generan tanta preocupación por
así decirlo italia es una bomba de
relojería que puede estallar en
cualquier momento precisamente por eso
parece difícil que el banco central
europeo pueda dejar de financiar la
fiesta
la única razón por la que italia no está
calificada como deuda basura es porque
las agencias de 'rating' asumen que el
banco central europeo de un paso para
prevenir el default en este sentido los
bonos italianos son de hecho bonos
alemanes ion rubino la pregunta es hasta
cuándo se podrá sostener esta situación
pero ahora que ya sabemos que está
ocurriendo la pregunta que podemos
hacernos es cómo se ha llegado hasta
este punto atentos
el origen del problema
hace poco tiempo dedicamos uno de
nuestros vídeos a como italia había
llegado a esta situación básicamente
podemos resumirlo en falta de
competitividad durante años a los
políticos italianos la economía les ha
importado un rábano mientras el mundo
cambiaba a toda velocidad
italia castigaba a las empresas con
impuestos altísimos y un montón de
regulaciones de todo tipo además
mientras tanto el estado no dejaba de
contratar más y más funcionarios y
gastaba dinero a espuertas sin que los
resultados importarán absolutamente nada
por ejemplo tan sólo uno de cada cinco
jóvenes italianos obtiene un título
universitario una tasa que es casi la
mitad que la media de la ocde y claro si
no estás preparando a tus jóvenes y
encima te olvidas de ser competitivo
entonces qué otra cosa puedes esperar
por si no fuera suficiente al pertenecer
al euro sabéis qué ocurre que los
políticos italianos ya no pueden
utilizar uno de sus trucos favoritos de
evaluar la moneda en fin amigos esta es
la historia que explica las noticias
tenebrosas que de vez en cuando aparecen
en los medios de comunicación como veis
la situación es muy pero que muy
complicada aquí en visual político
trataremos de seguir todos los
acontecimientos pero ahora turno para ti
crees que el gobierno italiano debe
romper con bruselas déjame tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta y este vídeo está resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a visual político si aún no
lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima